and now a video i gotta do it i gotta do
it it's been a while guys haven't seen
it in a while
uh this is sunny hostin sunny hostin is
a crazy racist woman who is just the
worst of the worst if you if you want to
find someone if you're not sure what you
think about the world right
if you just don't know what you think
about the world you don't have time to
watch dave rubin you don't have time to
you know really think things through you
should just watch clips of sunny hostin
and if sonny hostin says something if
you believe the reverse you'll be in
good shape i really believe that's a way
to live it's it's a way to live here's
sonny hostin trying to explain to us
that it's the democrats who are the
moderates they are playing to the base i
mean if you look at all the studies the
republican party has moved further to
the right than democrats have to the
left there's a pew research um center
analysis that finds that on average
democrats and republicans are farther
apart ideologically today than at any
time in the past 50 years and that
ideological divide breaks down to the
republican party being an extremist
party and this the democratic party
actually as you just mentioned sarah
moving more to the center but isn't the
problem that is the primaries because
you can't get through these primaries
unless you are extreme
okay
she's she's just an idiot the pew
research that she uh quoted there has
nothing to do with what she said her
argument was that the republicans have
become
more extreme and then she's saying that
the parties the what the pew research
poll was about was that the parties have
moved far apart but it's not because the
republicans went crazy the republicans
you can argue have moderated in a
million different ways hey say gay
marriage for one that was a big one for
a long time right are there republicans
really screaming about gay marriage
anymore remember it was only six seven
eight years ago that the republicans ran
several candidates who were vehemently
against gay marriage right remember mike
huckabee remember rick santorum right
they all moved on that because of that
orange guy right who ran against who ran
for gay marriage you know he was for
same-sex marriage as a first-time
candidate unlike that barack obama guy
big homophobe that guy remember that um
so you could say that's one you could
also say that republicans even on
abortion even on abortion are more
moderate why could you say that well
here in a place in a red state run by
right-wing maniac ron desantis we have a
15-week ban on abortion that's three and
a half months that's a moderate position
because that's pro a pro-life state a
conservative state saying oh we will
compromise we are not going to try to
outlaw abortion altogether we're not
even going to go for six weeks or 10
weeks or 12 weeks which i would be okay
with they're saying three and a half
freaking months and it passed just six
weeks ago and it goes into effect in
july that's a
moderate republican position what's the
democrat position on abortion well uh
just last week every single democrat
in the house voted that there should be
no limits on abortion ever yes
eight-month abortions eight-month
abortions so who is more moderate the
people that want to rip eight-month
babies out of the woman murder them or
the people who are saying 15-week
abortions
on top of gay marriage and we could do a
whole bunch more on this stuff i think
you got my point